たこあげです
一回、普通に飛ばしてみます
うぉおおおお
わあっはっはっはっは笑
わぁあああ〜〜〜
あっはっはっはっは笑
あ、すごい、すごい
あぁあああああ
あっはっはっはっは笑
あああぁぁぁぁぁはっはっ笑
っていう、たこあげがあるんですけれども
たこあげ、
みなさんしたこと
ありますでしょうか。
僕は多分、ないです
多分、ないんですけど
今、なんか普通にやってみたら
結構上がって、楽しかったんですけど
たこあげって、このひもで
このヒューってたこを
上まで飛ばして
こうなんか、わぁ〜、
すごいね、すごいね
って見るだけなんですけど
この糸ってどれくらいなんだろう
サイズ書いてないんで
ちょっと測ってみましょう
一回、ひもの長さがどれくらいか、
確かめてみましょう
長ぇぇぇぇぇぇ
は、ここまで
ここまででーす！
じゃあ、長さ測ります
はいっ！
はい、だいたいですね
42メートルくらいです
はい、というわけで
ひもの長さが42メートルくらいあることが
分かりました
で、今回、ちょっと僕が試したいのは
たこあげって
どれくらい高く
飛ぶんじゃね？
っていうところ？！
既存のたこあげだと
42メートルが限界です
そして、え〜
もっと上に行くために
ひもを準備しました
450メートルあるんで
うまくいけば、
最大高さ500メートルまで
たこが揚がります
日本の領空守ってるっけ？
領空に決まった高度は
定義されていないんだって、今
ということは、まあ
100キロくらいまで高さなら
大丈夫なんで
500メートルくらい大丈夫
だと思います
まずはとりあえず、
このたこで42メートル
飛ぶかどうか、
試していきましょう
では、いこう
まず、10メートルくらい
揚げてみます
行きますっ！
うぇーい、余裕
余裕、余裕
え、めっちゃすげえ
めっちゃすげぇ
10メートルは余裕です
10メートルくらいは
全然余裕です
じゃあ、次は20メートルくらい
いってみましょう
結構、20ってすごいよね
いきまーすっ！
ぉおおっほっほ
余裕っ！
余裕っす！
うぁああああ！
30メートルいきます！
こんくらい
ぇえええ〜へっへっへ
へっへっへっへ
ふぇええええ
30メートルいったんすけど、
たぶん余裕すぎます
このまま一気に、あの〜
42メートルまでいっちゃいましょう
このまま、かき上がってやんぜ
42メートルっ！
や〜もう、めっちゃ高いんだよな
いや、余裕だな
え〜待って
高すぎて、やばいんだけど、これ
まだ？まだ行く？
やばい、やばい、やばい、やばい、やばい、やばい
はいっ、出来ました！
これが42メートルですっ！
全然飛ぶ、でも
はい、というわけで、
42メートル、くそ余裕でした
というわけで、ここからこの糸に、
更に糸をくっつけて
何メートルまで飛ばせるか、
実験してみたいと思います
待って、降りねぇ〜
降りねぇな、これ
ふふっ、これ、降りねぇ〜
よし、多分もう
取れないと思います
合計500メートルの高さまでいける
たこあげが完成しました
はい、というわけで、あとは
このたこを
何メートルまで揚げられるか。
行ってきます(☆Д☆)
50メートル余裕です
バッチリです！
はい、というわけで、今、
多分、60メートルくらいです
もうちょい、のばしてみましょう(☆Д☆)
もう、やばいね
もう100いってね？！、これ
これ行ってるね笑
キター（≧∇≦）
あ〜、100メートルいきました
あそこにあります、今
やばいね、結構すごいんすよ
こわっ
飛行機にぶつかられるか心配です
もうちょい飛ばしてみましょう
次、150いってみます
待って、もうやばいかも
エターナルやな？！
落ちちゃう、落ちちゃう
待って、急速に落ちちゃう
やばいっ
あ〜〜〜〜〜
落ちちゃった笑